para muy bien venidos de la entrevista
de france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña daniel feierstein él es
sociólogo también doctor en ciencias
sociales e investigador del consejo
nacional de investigaciones científicas
y técnicas de argentina hablamos del
conicet junto a él vamos a abordar la
pandemia de coronavirus kobe 19 pero
desde una perspectiva sociológica para
poder analizar determinadas reacciones
sociales frente a esta crisis y frente
por supuesto a las medidas de
aislamiento social que han marcado y
marcan todavía de la vida de todas las
personas a lo largo de todo el mundo
daniel feierstein en primer lugar
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
usted ha planteado que las estrategias
para frenar los contagios de coronavirus
estarían fracasando y hace referencia a
dos importantes sistemas de defensa
psíquica que operan a nivel colectivo en
las sociedades por un lado habla usted
de la negación y por el otro de la
protección puede ir de a desarrollar
estos conceptos
son muchas las formas de afección
emocional pero dos que me parecería
importante tomar en cuenta son estos dos
tipos de procesos una es la negación y
la negación tiene que ver con una
respuesta de una situación que nos pone
como de cara ante la muerte o ante la
posibilidad de la muerte de los seres
queridos que nos pone en una situación
de transformación muy abrupta de nuestra
vida cotidiana
una defensa protectiva común es hacer
como si esa situación no existiera esto
es negar esa situación de muy distintas
maneras eso es una reacción bastante una
una reacción bastante natural bastante
protectiva del sistema psíquico el
problema es que después se puede
articular en formas de racionalización
que es lo que se suele llamar negación y
cuando eso ya se transforma en una
teoría que niega la realidad si por
ejemplo el virus no existe o éste las
muertes no son tantas o
de distintos modos intentar o la gente
se muere de cacos o se van a morir igual
sin formas como ven a realizar o negar
la realidad y después tenemos la
estructura de la proyección que
generalmente aparece después que es que
cuando el enojo el resentimiento la
frustración que nos produce una
situación que no podemos controlar que
no podemos manejar una realidad que nos
resulta muy difícil como requerir
encontrar una forma de desviar ese odio
buscando algún responsable algún
culpable de la situación para dirigir
hacia ese culpable el odio y eso en la
lógica de la proyección que tiene que
ver con poner el problema en otro y esto
se vincula también a formas de reacción
que han aparecido sobre todo que pueden
aparecer intentando desde distintos
grupos no desde los chinos a los
inmigrantes hasta los que viven en
barrios populares hasta el personal de
salud los judíos los gitanos digo a lo
largo de la historia siempre se ha
buscado encontrar algún grupo
sobre el cual arrojar la responsabilidad
para de ese modo sacarme la angustia
ahora daniel vemos en argentina y
también en países de todo el mundo
manifestaciones anti cuarentena y en
algunas incluso se suelen escuchar
teorías conspirativas bastante
llamativas como explica usted de estas
movilizaciones esta suerte de rechazo a
las medidas de aislamiento social yo
creo que hay como dos elementos
fundamentales no uno contra el que es
muy difícil luchar pero otro que quizás
si se podría abordar uno es esto que
decíamos de un negacionismo muy extremo
muy literal que lleva determinados
grupos directamente a plantear que todo
esto es mentira y que esto esto no
existe y esto es muy difícil porque es
alguien que estaría ya en el en el linde
del delirio pero creo que no son grupos
tan importantes pasa que han tomado la
calle porque gran parte de la sociedad
ha aceptado no salir a la calle no me
parece que ahí como que tenemos un
núcleo que hemos visto todo el mundo
porque está en argentina pero también
está en alemania por plantear algo en
una sociedad muy distinta a la argentina
entonces me parece que bueno ahí tenemos
como un núcleo
pero después me parece que se vincula
esto que decía de algunas sociedades que
no han podido como irse adecuando a un
cambio de la situación entonces que
inicialmente la única herramienta era un
aislamiento hasta tanto ir construyendo
una nueva normalidad pero después se
requería empezar a pensar formas de
salida de ese aislamiento y forma de
construcción de un nuevo sistema de
cuidados y como esto no se fue
desarrollando en general mucha gente
comenzó a sentirse del mismo modo que
estos negadores radicales extremos y de
pronto esas marchas empezaron a tener
algún nivel mayor de acompañamiento que
no son solamente los delirantes o
digamos decir sino mucha gente que
encuentra que no puede seguir
sosteniendo una mecánica de tanto
aislamiento y que que se encuentran como
muy podemos es decir muy conmocionada
por la incertidumbre por la dificultad
para saber qué hacer por el miedo y
bueno y se termina expresando de esta
manera lo que creo que es
tremendamente negativo creo que hay que
pensar cómo separar estos dos grupos
como este poder actuar sobre aquellos
que no están incluidos en el marco de
teorías conspirativas y en posiciones
más delirantes sino que encuentran
dificultades para las cuales necesitan
alguna respuesta estatal
un poco más realista
ahora sí bien por supuesto no es posible
de no generalizar como evalúa usted los
comportamientos sociales frente a la
pandemia a más de seis meses ya de su
inicio bueno creo que esto ha ido
cambiando sociedad a sociedad o sea me
parece que hay jugaron varias cuestiones
por un lado que tan instaladas de estar
en distintas sociedades normas básicas
de cooperación entonces lo que hemos
visto que por ejemplo en muchas
sociedades orientales pero para el caso
también en estados como cuba o en otros
lugares del mundo donde donde hay un
respeto por ese lazo social donde hay un
reconocimiento de la estructura
comunitaria ha sido más fácil
estructurar acciones de cuidado porque
básicamente hay esto como un tejido
comunitario y un respeto por la norma en
esos en esos lugares jugo de modos muy
positivos y tenemos otro conjunto de
sociedades y en esto ha entrado mucho
las sociedades latinoamericanas aunque
no solamente
en donde se mezcla una una constante
destrucción las últimas décadas de ese
tejido comunitario de esa confianza en
el otro y un histórico desprecio por el
cumplimiento de la norma podríamos decir
entonces esta articulación ha vuelto muy
problemático establecer acciones y ha
generado el crecimiento de estos modos
negacionistas ahora eso tendríamos que
agregarle que a veces el desconcierto
con el que algunos gobiernos han lidiado
con la situación
ha colaborado en esa forma generación
porque no se observa un plan estratégico
porque no se observa una direccionalidad
porque ahora lo único a lo que se
recurre es a quedarse en casa y esto que
puede ser muy efectivo para periodos
cortos se vuelven muy disfunciones para
períodos muy largos de tiempo donde lo
que hay que pensar es en lógicas de
reducción de daños de construcción de
una nueva normalidad rutina de cuidado y
no pensar que la gente se puede quedar
una cantidad muy larga de tiempo una
cantidad muy larga de meses sin retomar
determinadas actividades en lugar de
entender buenos cuáles pueden retomar
cuáles no como qué tipo de cuidados
tiene que implementar cómo ir
acompañando el dinamismo que ha tenido
la situación ahora daniel qué puede
suceder en particular en sociedades
donde sus líderes políticos como por
ejemplo no sé brasil contra ir bolsonaro
o eeuu con donald trauma tienden a
restarle importancia al virus más que
que podría suceder en países como
estados unidos y brasil podemos decir
que sucede en países como eeuu y brasil
son los dos países con el número más
alto de muertes y con el número más alto
de contagios esto es efectivamente si es
muy problemática
la respuesta negadora ante una pandemia
que esa respuesta sea encarada
directamente por el poder político que
han sido muy pocos los casos pero son
algunos de los que mencionadas hay
algunos más pero básicamente los dos
casos emblemáticos son el brasil de
bolsonaro
lo que observas lo que estamos viendo o
sea que hay un absoluto desprecio por la
vida y que como irradia desde la cima
del poder político ratifica toda esa
tendencia a la negación que puede tener
la sociedad y entonces vuelve a
imposible el cuidado cuando el propio
gobierno es el que lleva a cabo la
negación bueno esto es infinitamente más
grave porque entonces ya de ninguna
manera puede lidiar con una negación
social un gobierno que está en estado de
negación te voy a mencionar ahora al
investigador del conicet a roberto
echenique quien identificó la bajada en
los picos de contagios y de muertes en
algunos países con lo que él denomina la
inmunidad del cagazo aclarado caso es un
término bastante coloquial utilizado en
algunos países de la región para
referirse a una sensación de miedo
verdad danielle de qué se trata esta
inmunidad
qué es lo que dice chen y que es muy
rico el análisis que la inmunidad se
construye sobre la población que circula
no sobre la población total entonces uno
puede tener una inmunidad de rebaño que
es muy difícil de lograr que sería esa
inmunidad que se construye sobre el
total de la población suponiendo que
circula el total de la población ahora
sí se da este fenómeno de cagado de
miedo de que hay una parte muy
importante de la población que restringe
su movimiento los que circulan son
muchos menos y entonces la inmunidad se
construye sobre esos pocos que circulan
entonces porque le da otro nombre y está
muy bien el nombre que le da más allá de
la broma parece preciso porque es un
tipo de miedo además ese ese caso sería
el miedo que nos obliga a quedarnos
encerrados a no querer salir ahora
justamente ese caso lo que hace es
construir inmunidad porque hace que
salgan muy pocos y que esos pocos que
salen se inmunicen en sí y son mucho más
rápido de pronto se inmuniza pongamos
por poner un número
por ciento de la población no el 20 por
ciento por acción son los que circulan
se inmunizan y luego el virus no circula
más ahora qué pasa cuándo empiezan a
salir esos que estaban con gas o si el
ciclo comienza otra vez
porque si todavía hay suficientes
semillas que puedan contagiar en la
sociedad empiezan a salir los
susceptibles de su primer problema y el
segundo problema es creer que ese caso
va a llegar con tal número de muertos y
eso no está establecido esto es eso es
un proceso totalmente subjetivo entonces
una sociedad puede decidir que tiene
miedo y se queda con 50 muertos por día
o con 100 muertos por día y otra
sociedad puede tener 1000 muertos por
día y no tener ningún miedo y no
quedarse en la casa entonces lo que hay
que entender es que ese tipo de
inmunidad no es un hecho natural así
como el pico no es un hecho natural así
como la inmunidad de rebaño no es un
hecho natural son hechos que tienen que
ver con los comportamientos sociales y
por eso hay que estudiar y entender los
comportamientos daniel feierstein
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 ha sido un
placer dialogar con usted a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos como siempre a
continuar informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y recuerden que
pueden volver a ver esta entrevista y
muchas otras en france24 punto com
[Música]
y